I think we live in this perception where
we believe that if we wish if we want if
we wait love will arrive fully formed
when in fact it's really about
intentionally building it step by step
and I'm usually one for breaking rules
but I believe that there are rules of
love that actually help us navigate the
challenges to prepare for the
imperfections to accept that there will
be conflict there will be breakdowns
there will be disagreements often we
think that love is perfect and that love
is easy and that love should just flow
and that's true it can be that way but
we often forget the difference between a
relationship with yourself and a
relationship with someone else is that
you go from dealing with one mind to
dealing with two minds